an explosive new report raises fresh
questions about how uber handles
passenger safety the Washington Post
report focuses on uber special
investigations unit that handles some of
the worst incidents reported by
passengers The Post says agents in this
unit or coach to put the company first
ahead of passenger safety now uber
disputes those allegations it comes as a
ride-hailing company and bills new
safety features to protect customers so
first on CBS this morning Kris Van
Cleave shows us a new technology uber
hopes this new technology could help
prevent the kind of fatal error police
believe Samantha Josephson made when she
mistook a car for her uber in March
Hoover really felt that responsibility
to step up even though that was not an
uber driver tracee Breeden is a former
police officer who now heads women's
safety in uber but to step up and see
what more we could do to create a safer
environment soon a new optional
verification system will require a
driver to get a pin code from their
rider before a trip can start the trial
enters the pin you get an indication or
notification on your phone saying yes
this is the right car but it's something
to do before you get in the car so that
it's checking the license plate checking
the name and now with the pin
verification you should confirm that
before you get in the car uber wants to
take this pin verification system a step
further so soon
your phone will seamlessly talk to the
phone of the uber you've called it will
then tell you when the right vehicle has
pulled up that your ride is verified and
this is the car to get into next month
first in Los Angeles and then elsewhere
riders can text 911 inside the app
automatically sending the vehicle
description license plate current
location and destination you'll also be
able to report safety issues to uber
during a ride I think these are smart
changes wired editor-in-chief Nick
Thompson but with so many drivers and so
many passengers they're not gonna make
the entire problem of passenger safety
go away the new features come as the
ride sharing industry faces scrutiny
over passenger safety just this month
more than a dozen women suit competitor
lyft
alleging it mishandled
of sexual assault lyft says safety is
fundamental adding it launched 14 new
safety features this year
uber is facing similar lawsuits and
there are new questions about the
company's handling of sexual assault
claims The Washington Post reports the
company has a three-strike system but
executives have made exceptions to keep
drivers on the road one former
investigator says she was made to feel
her first priority was to protect uber
not the customer investigators do not
report any of the incidents that
happened on the uber app to law
enforcement the lack of communication
between the right share apps really puts
people in a very dangerous position but
Breeden told us as soon as a sexual
assault or misconduct is reported the
driver is removed from the platform how
often do you receive a report of an
alleged sexual assault or abuse we're
doing 17 million trips across the world
every day every day and it does happen
do you see tens of those reports a year
hundreds of those reports a year those
are numbers that I don't have and that's
why we're creating this transparency
report and that information is coming
that would be a first for the industry
but uber was not able to tell CBS News
win that transparency report would be
available for CBS this morning Kris Van
Cleave San Francisco